Glen Campbell was a country boy who made
it big with success in music television
and film he was born in a small town in
Arkansas around 1960 the young musician
moved to Los Angeles becoming a session
musician playing for the likes of Dean
Martin Elvis Presley Frank Sinatra and
Meryl Haggard but it wasn't until 1967
that he hit it big with the release of
two blockbuster albums
gentle on my mine which won two Grammy
Awards and by the time I get to Phoenix
also garnering two Grammys Campbell was
on a hot streak and in 1968 came Wichita
Lineman sitting on Billboard's Hot 100
charts for 15 weeks
Campbell capitalized on this popularity
and turned to television from 1969
through 1972 he hosted a variety show
the Glen Campbell goodtime hour he also
tried his hand as an actor co-starring
in the iconic film True Grit and
performing the theme song which went on
to be nominated for an Academy Award but
in the midst of his success Campbell
became ensnared in controversy his
on-again off-again relationship with
singer Tanya Tucker became tabloid
fodder he also battled an alcohol and
drug addiction that he would later kick
I just welcomed said I can I can quit
this I know I can and I was like I said
I prayed and I prayed
but Campbell continued to enjoy musical
success the song rhinestone Cowboys shot
to number one on the Billboard charts in
1975 and he'd peak again in 77 with the
song southern night in 2005 the star was
inducted into the Country Music Hall of
Fame but in 2011 he shocked the music
world with a stunning announcement what
they diagnosed me is Alzheimer's
Alzheimer's mm-hmm what's all Alzheimer
the 75 year old entertainer decided to
bow out of the business and embark on a
final tour with a band featuring three
of his children the music world rallied
around the icon in 2012 he received a
Lifetime Achievement Award at the
Grammys taking the stage to perform
admits a star-studded tribute all I
wanted to do ever since I could remember
was let's play my guitar and sing